I hope I can help necromancy may be
legal in Cyrodiil but few will openly
admit to practicing it now that the
mages guild has banned it farewell
may you rest in peace oh yeah play video
games watch someone else play video
that's right I'm joining you guys how
stupid can you be
come on you guys have been doing it for
years well I can't do it oblivion is
it's my weakness this game is just God's
gift to earth Thank You Todd Howard son
thank you
fun fact ton Howard was in the Chess
Club nothing cracks me up like this game
so let's just jump into it the other one
got deleted in case anyone is curious
what happened to it but we have a ton of
new of Lybian memes thanks to bacon who
apparently took it upon himself to
single-handedly resurrect this this game
what's going on
stop you bow or serve your sentence your
stolen goods are now forfeit then pay
with your blood that's great this game
is too good I never actually played this
game I just know I love it that's all I
know Todd Howard god bless your soul and
they clearly were way too ambitious with
this title and that's what makes it so
goddamn beautiful I was writing games
when I was you know 12 whatever and the
other kids in the block would say you
know I'm gonna play quarterback for the
Cowboys and I'd be like I'm gonna make
video games and everyone's gonna play
you dork go back to the Chess Club who's
laughing now yes I was in the Chess Club
[Laughter]
who's laughing now I like how it goes
from confident to insecure just like
that
who's laughing now yeah
god bless you Todd I'm Rena brilliant I
love dogs
doesn't everyone everyone does how do
you get that perfect timing
god damn it only in Oblivion I am ready
burn it one thing you need to know about
me I love dogs
does it every how does that happen
what in most games these days it's all
about you know Duck and Cover and and
wait for your enemy to come out and then
you know waiting for the right move it's
a lot of waiting is very boring but not
nothing speaks like a real action movie
nothing tops the matrix times a hundred
thousand million like the Oblivion
combat just why Brittani
[Music]
you're pathetic take that goddamn it
when you fail at the long range
you just gotta step in on that close
range you're pathetic
beautiful with that fire now ain't it a
surprise no sign of them they do that in
LA a lot it that's Skyrim to be fair but
they do that in life just kill someone
immediately that's no sign of him I
guess he's gone
oh my god does everyone have a
dislocated shoulder what is going on
wait what the hell is this
Oh Todd Howard seduces you too Matt
they're mad at Fleetwood Mac's right
it's me Bethesda's Todd Howard look I
know you told me not to come around and
know after we bought skyrim for the Xbox
one you said you were done at least let
me plead my case no poor is the perfect
game it'll have no lobe time yeah did
you like that no I can't I'm sorry I'll
save this for later yes
oh great and mighty grand champion is
there something you need can I carry
your weapon shine your boots that road
perhaps where it's gonna shoot room in
the air oh is it the classic oh gee you
sure okay well I'll be hanging around
the arena grounds if you need someone to
share the ground you walk on
absolutely beautiful absolutely
magnificent oh my god he just broke his
back he's fine he's fine it happens all
the time
he does that all the time happening
this game is so confusing
I think that's why it makes it so good
you see someone run past just now well
if you do grab him and yell it bastard
stole from me did you see thump is that
how Americans try to do like Nordic
accent is that is that how you see yes
huh racism have you seen anyone in plain
sight do you see that man right there
you know the action is very exciting of
in oblivion and Skyrim of course but
nothing really entices me and immerses
me like the dialogue that really makes
me feel like I'm part of the world it
feels like real dialogues real people
real communication how goes it
I've been better I hope things get
better
oh hello how are you today I've been
how about you I've been better what's
the news from the other parts of Tamriel
nothing and I'd like to talk about so
long be seeing you at first I thought it
was the same guy just talking to himself
but it's clearly the same voice actor
for these two characters interacting
I've been better
how are you been better it's as long as
like this same person or something it's
incredible I already show this one but
it's so funny
this guy's an absolute an absolute
menace to society I don't know you know
it's this about I don't know you and I
don't they they test this game at all
and I don't care okay we get it thank
you
that is literally me at school to
everyone I don't know you I don't care
to know you
Thank You Pat sir the voice acting is
just impeccable lady
amber Knox has hired a new captain lady
amber Knox has hired a new captain of
the guard Todd did that intentionally I
know he did Spriggans nature's Guardians
my foot mean things they'll curse you or
they might call a bear to tear you apart
Spriggans nature's Guardians my foot
mean things they'll curse you or they
might call a bear to tear you apart wow
it's so nice to see a game that really
articulates all the points that they
want to say it feels like I'm talking to
a real person
don't you feel it too smash like if you
feel it too thank you something that's
really innovative for video games is the
fact that characters will actually
remember their interaction with you like
that one Lord of the Rings game for
example that definitely does not occur
in oblivion I mean oblivion really lives
up to his name because it seems like a
blue everyone just having amnesia I'm
captain of the castle guard and Deon is
captain of the town guard it's simple I
don't care what goes on in town
that's Dion's problem goodbye you're the
gray fox you're under arrest for for for
all kinds of stuff you're wanted dead or
alive i'm i'm choosing dead
i'll make captain for this oh great
man down he was just a captain that
wanted to be captain so sad
only asking for enough to thank you
later gather blessings of the shadow
upon thank you sir sir get blessings of
akatosh upon ye thank you kind sir
blessings of the shadow upon ye blessing
upon you for smashing like on this video
thank you can't there he was here a
second ago you I've seen your kind
before you've got blood on your hands
keep your blade sheath you murdering
bastard or I'll put you down myself
stay safe citizen say saves our dark
times you just murdered some wine how
could you do this spell looks dangerous
keep your distance
damnit will we ever get games like this
anymore
I doubt it your money or your money or
your life you're smarter than you look
seems fair they have braids in his hair
take it it's worthless to me anyway
the whole video of me just goddamnit I
laughed at that how does that happen you
see this highwayman at existential
crisis after you stole from him you see
he makes a living stealing from others
and yet he himself was just robbed you
can't say you were in the wrong since
he's done worse I mean yeah I guess he's
just calling us worthless isn't he
because he was comparing our life to the
money take it it's worthless to me
anyway
yeah it's oddly like sad but of course
the top of the cake the cake of the cake
the cake inside the cake the guards of
course nothing beats the AI anyway okay
oblivion really has mastered AI it
doesn't get any cleverer the cleverer
really smarter than this what is it very
subtle stop right there criminal scum
nobody breaks the law and my watch I'm
confiscating your stolen goods now pay
your fine or it's off to jail then pay
with your blood see my mascara watch out
take the [ __ ] do well sir officer she
says all flesh and no fury I can't tell
you it keeps stealing so it's a perfect
long live the Empire what's going on
it's all over law breaker your sprees at
an inner I'll take any stolen could you
have the next move is yours pay your
fine or I'll haul you away then pay with
your blood it's all over Anakin I have
the high ground alright that's it guys
going right to subscribe to bacon I'll
link his channel down below he is still
uploading these I wouldn't be able to
make this video without it and honestly
it's so funny
I I it's kind of weird I I feel like I
shouldn't play the game because I have
this expectation in my head that every
interaction is gonna be like this now
because all I've ever seen from it but
if you guys wanted me to play the game I
think I would be up for I think it could
be fun
I don't know but if you enjoyed this
video smash like and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
hope this video it was enjoyable I'm
sure it was thank you very much goodbye
brofist
[Music]